i anda nada era muito voltado a todos
votar no meu nome é bruno oliveira e sou
eu o ministro essa é uma frase que até
há bem pouco tempo não pensava de
exercerem um gozo é só que há
sensivelmente cinco anos atrás tem 23
portanto quando eu tinha 16 anos
o tempo é mágico foi assim um caminho
espontâneo amplo porque na verdade a
história é muito simples e optou hoje
por trazer antes de fazer dois números
que eu trouxe bastante particular por um
ponto que vamos ver mais à frente eu
também optei por ouvir falar um caminho
do que isto é mais direto a gente sabe
que o mágico é um artista que faz
números incríveis parece que aquilo que
nós mostramos é facto algo que é
impossível de acontecer mas também para
além disso há uma parte bastante
intrínseca na arte e que provavelmente
vocês não estão no ramo diz conhecer
algumas que são factos muito curiosos e
engraçados e que optar também por trazer
para portugal convosco
então vou trazer o tempo trazendo assim
um caminho na minha história porque
basicamente eu tinha 27 anos e estava em
81 mortos
ama matar muito pacato ninguém roubar
ninguém num assalto ronaldo velho
ninguém rouba emblemas bem vamos lá
mínima hipótese acontecer
hum é verdade então estava num bar é um
bairro conhecido que honrar não sei se
alguém conhece alguém foi para a zona
para estarem aqui com foram é então
estava lá numa tarde com dois amigos
meus e deus para não temos nada para
fazer nem luz para apoiar no horário
damos um baralho de cartas e começamos a
fazer alguns truques
só que o um truque o qq um deus me fez
com que o deixou completamente o fato é
que é possível que o ter acontecido em
um deles como é contra o prefeito
eu fui pesquisar como é que isto foi
feito após uma grande pesquisa para
saber como é contra o prefeito
fiquei para além do espetáculo realizado
outro campo e fiquei tão tomado como
engenhão e dado um método com a
criatividade do truque ou seja com a
criação da qual possam o que optei por
continuar a aprofundar
hoje os dois nada tem a ver com magia um
deus aulas nos testes o outro eu estou
na upa em ciências da comunicação é e os
chefes acção no pingo doce também é
componente rio tinto na vanguarda do
emprego é verdade
então eu continuar e aprofundar aquilo
na altura estava no no 12º ano e então
comecei a pesquisar assim mais alguns
truques e depois mais tarde eu tenho
nesse momento um ano de prática e então
ano foi criada a escola modelo português
margem de profissionais quais são meus
colegas de profissão e trabalha
diretamente com eles que o magic miranda
eo mágico gonçalves não somos mágicos
oficinais criaram a tecnologia do porto
e então eu formular o plano foi as luzes
que eu tive aqui é o início e então
depois conseguiu progredir e quando eu
achei que já tenha um bom produto para
mostrar o álbum já conseguia ram além de
fazer outro problema o técnico tem que
desenvolver já tem uma coisa muito mais
importante do que esse que é um chip que
é vencer em tratar porque aquilo que
maggi também deve ter em conta é que o
truque em si num ato uma atuação igual a
cerca de 20% a 80% é turvo
acho romântico presença em palco
dinâmica fazer sobretudo público passar
um bom bocado
então quando eu achei que já estava num
nível aceitável que enfrentam ao tentar
procurar trabalho porque eu decidi que
queria mesmo fazer destruída
creio mesmo profissionalizarmos porque
era que o que motivava a trabalhar mais
no qualquer outro ramo
e então o que eu fiz foi eu comecei a
pesquisar por empresas de eventos são os
eventos quintas para casamentos
formaturas casamentos um dos eventos
mais requisitados para mágicos
apesar de ser invulgar encontrar a
imagem com o casamento os casamentos são
em grande parte
a nossa fonte de rendimento e van
você procura começa a mandar manhã fui
diretamente essas instituições fizeram
uma demonstração do que eu sabia e
pronto temos nos primeiros eventos no
início como é óbvio
tive que trabalhar à borla porque o que
eu queria era uma necessidade mais do
que até propriamente o dinheiro e
conseguiram fazer alguns eventos ea
publicidade que mais me ajudou foi o
passa-palavra pessoas viam estava no
casamento e depois comentavam a uma casa
próxima
olhou conseguiu mais do que um casamento
foi qualquer coisa espetacular então nos
olhavam e contratavam então
provavelmente ainda assim acontece
problemas casamentos mas também eventos
particulares jantar por exemplo essas
universitários crianças com milhões
enfim todos os eventos táctica também
está vai passar a estar no meu currículo
em prontidão desde aí conceiã ã um e 16
a profissionalizar mais tarde até
recentemente fui contratado para
trabalhar numa loja online amazon no ano
que vem truques chamas oportunidade
o proprietário é preciso muito mais do
que joão miranda eu estou a trabalhar no
escritório da empresa janeiro as vendas
sua posse os vídeos dos truques as
discussões os vídeos explicativos
sou eu sugiro que o material é que vai
nos nossos fornecedores não sou eu que
estou neste momento a tratar da estão
todas a loja e também antes disso
consegue também a trabalhar na produção
dos frutos porque como é que isso
funciona o mágico acrescenta ao seu
repertório alguns trocos
os tanques podem ser da sua podem ter
sido criados por é originalmente bom não
é na comunidade mas o que acontece mas
que tem uma ideia um truque do truck e
velho pra todo mundo a diversos
distribuidores de arquivos de um cinismo
imagens e ouvir um tronco é o quinto no
horário o que eu gosto que eu gosto
tanto que eu acho que vai ter é
resultado
pronto o público eu compro dou o meu
tênis e quatro do homem a apresentação
outro pelo tamanho importante que nos
treinos unix aquilo que eu sei por quê
quando contratassem era que eu não quero
contratar um mágico quer contratar um
novo e velho é uma coisa completamente
diferente é certo porque o tempo ser um
líquido que eu faço tento dar a minha
personalidade
a minha própria apresentação outro para
não tornar o único e dessa forma
conseguir ter muito mais trabalho e
também irá e esta é um dos projetos mais
ambiciosos que saem com outro mais do
que alguns ao gil que nós neste momento
estamos a trabalhar numa rotina numa
atuação de cerca de oito minutos numa
via cômica e pretendemos que aliás vamos
a easynet junho apresentará a peça que
terá no congresso a espanha porque
existem congresso para mais com mais
feiras
enfim seja no ramo for vamos ver também
o congresso ea feira as conduz os
dólares magia os trabalhadores
apresentam os grupos têm todos os
mágicos viu nem nesta cidade uma cidade
que for e os magics compram truks vai lá
dentro que vem conferências e outros
mágicos vem espetáculos a competições e
aquilo que nós pretendemos fazer nesse
congresso que vai ser enganada dia 18 de
junho
vamos então ver vamos concorrer ao
campeonato espanhol que o congresso mais
importante de espanha
iremos concorrer com a nossa rotina e
mais tarde o que nós pretendemos ter o
campeonato do mundo afirma ofício à
federação internacional das sociedades
mágicas basicamente é fifa da magia
isso é tocar dos blatter diz não a este
não há é filho de mazinho ou seja a
entidade que gera todo ramo da magia no
mundo é o campeonato mais realizar em
2018 e vai ser em busan na coréia do sul
mas para já o projecto mais ambicioso e
podem ver o que eu fiz foi van é tentar
então procurar profissionalizar o que
tem que ser através dos meus próprios
mas só como foi o exemplo do bruno souza
que a época em que foi ontem eu estive a
trabalhar no escritório precisa dessa
loja e só tenho o costume lá ver essa
conferência do início ao fim e fiquei
muito impressionado porque o mesmo muito
valor às pessoas que tentam eu procurar
através das suas próprias mais fazer
aquilo que gostam e desenvolver um plano
a aceitável para depois poderem vir a
servir somente eu poderia fazer neste
viva e foi também o pensamento que eu
fiz há alguns fatos curiosos na magia
mas também gostaria de partilhar com
vocês podem ver para eu estar aqui
existe muito mais trabalho por trás
tive que aprender continuamente a
próxima apresentação constructions
twitter que em troncos de outros males
que para poder apresentar o meu
repertório e por exemplo há um caso de
um mágico muito muito conhecido já não
estavam ativos não posso precisar isso
chamava por miguel a
o legal ela dizia que tenha poder se
dizia mesmo tempo poder que era então
muito mágico ano e houve uma vez que o
processaram a um certo produto ser uma
fralda e eu tendo assim conseguiu ganhar
o caso
confio que provar que tenho o fato de
poder até que um dia foi a provisão e eu
tenho um grupo de montanhistas que
conseguir dobrar creche dobrar as
mulheres
mas o que é engraçado é que eu ia sempre
como o senhor faqueiro atrás
tanto era só com aquelas crianças até
perguntaram a mas eu tenho aqui uma
colher faça com esta mulher e ela deu
uma desculpa esfarrapada então foi então
descoberto a careca de um de uma pessoa
que se dizia que éramos magic não existe
além disso o termo mágico e ilusionista
quer dizer a mesma coisa ninguém pudesse
não é hipótese que vai custava mas não é
tudo usando um truque se tudo possam
simplesmente para dar a entender ao
espectador de que alguém que sirva
aconteceu e com um único propósito
entreter mas nada é isso também com que
o magic tem que ter muito cuidado porque
o mágico deve fundamentalmente ano
mostrar outro que mostrar que aquilo
aconteceu para entreter as pessoas que
nunca para mostrar que é mais do corpo
muito alto ou seja eu sei mais do que
vocês
é eu sei como é que se faz vocês não
você chama o raul é não não pode ser
assim
eu simplesmente trabalhei para ter para
construir um novo cartório para o único
propósito de vôos entre ter certo é
apenas por voz
gaudí pois as pessoas param para ver é
bom e então que trouxe dois
dois presentes é muito engraçados tem
uma particularidade porque esse truque
foram criados por dois portugueses é
verdade é que podem ver mas em portugal
e atual por mais alguns mandos atacar
anos nem pensa que está em espanha tem
um programa na tv em espanha e além
disso também trabalha muito para mágicos
eo tamanho desenvolve produz e
comercializa entre a comunidade mágica
eu trouxe dois troncos ano não foram
criados por dois portugueses um deles
foi idealizado para o magic chamar
gustavo sereno já esteve aqui temos
cultural do ano passado
vocês se lembram alguns de vocês foi
idealizado por eua e foi produzido por
uma empresa que chama o infarmed que é o
curso proprietários são os nomes que já
falei há pouco
joão miranda gonçalves mil euros
basicamente tem ideias outros inovadores
ou seja que os procuram os procuram
ouvir os problemas que existem na magia
o acúmulo shows exército ou seja se é um
truque que pode ser potencializado
elas fazem um brainstorm e tentam dessa
forma criar aquilo que nós chamamos o
uruguai ou seja é impossível que o
truque ser mais mais perfeito no que é
ou seja e é isso que a magia está também
a caminhar ou seja nós mesmo momento nós
estamos aqui estamos a caminhar para que
as idéias de truques sejam tão mas tão
secretas igrejas estão de moleques que
as pessoas vão mesmo acreditar que foi
mesmo dia que aconteceu é que não há não
é possível haver um segredo por trás
aqui um aquilo que foi visto foi mesmo
mesmo dia e é isso que a magia está a
caminhar e fazendo agora um contraste
com a magia de um julgamento
quero só dar uma revisada acabaram os
cartolas
acabaram-se as varinhas e acabaram se os
fracos isso ainda é uma idéia muito
chata no público leigo e que assuma em
que se forem ver um espetáculo mágico
anda certeza que não vai usar uma
cartola e vai fazer por si por ser umas
flores mas por mais parece um reforço
vai fazer por ser um ex com uma caixa de
tamanho em que vai ser chamas não o tema
nossas peças das caixas que as caixinhas
dos cachorros
é neste momento é isso acabam ainda mais
discrição o caminho retrógradas que
ficaram temporada no tempo há uma razão
muito simples um ano para essa idéia
estava iluminada é que os machos que
utilizavam cartola marinha que é o fraco
aquela camisa cheia de fóruns
aquela capa crime até aqui é porque
daqui a um tempo eu estamos a falar pois
alguns anos 20
nunca nenhum essa indumentária dos
senhores vocês vêm por exemplo
fotografias dos anos 20 anos 30 em que
andavam com a cartola não foi um sonho
tudo pronto e essa era na altura a moda
que que se tem na altura portanto é raro
vocês verem pessoas em 93 anos 80 também
vêem música que vocês dizem é mais
próximos à vista é exatamente igual seja
tudo evolui todas as artes lo e as todos
os ramos evoluem e magia também dessa
forma e 8 e então vamos falar que
entrassem na verdade e eu optei por
gostou que mais na coluna zelador do
como artista eu optei por não trazer um
espetáculo não estar aqui fazendo
espetáculos sete minutos mas também
mostrarmos o que é isso da magia o que é
com ramon envolve é e o que motivou
precisamente a optar por este ano então
é o seguinte a magia não só que essas
mães que isto é importante ver que não
tem oil fantin cordas aqui dentro não
tem absolutamente nada então como a
magia que consegui fazer conseguir
produzir dinheiro não pagando 11 está
aqui exatamente tudo que uma nota muito
grande
certo é uma nota de cinco anos consegue
ver e rever a nota 5 horas completamente
normal não é falsa
então vamos mostrar como é que eu
consigo viver da magia é muito simples
pois pagam como suporte foi um orçamento
o espetáculo hã era bom trabalho não só
um pouco lenta então o que fazemos é por
causa da alta de 5
e começamos puro do barco assim a nota
certo o que acontece é que se superar a
nota com essa linha de outra forma e
para além de outra forma começa também a
ganhar outra cura e nota 5
fica com 10 um lado fica amarela e
transforma se numa nota de 50 da lei é
verdade como podem ver como podem ver é
assim que nós mágicos conseguimos ganhar
dinheiro é e engraçado porque tak1
palops
apesar de ganhar dinheiro minha carteira
está sempre vazia para não ter notas
aqui dentro tem um cartão do banif na
presença dela sobre isso mas não tenho
aqui o meu cartão os cartões no cartão
de saúde indica que o ginásio como podem
ver o efeito que uma coisa é o meu rei e
meu cartão de visitas e tomar é o órgão
pedirá ajuda a mostrar agora como é que
se chama eterna dúvida que o palco
chorão são paulo foi carolina vai fazer
o quarto do telex
o cara que joga com o cartão de visita
obrigatória do emergente
quero ver não macula o telex e estou
bastante contente por isso mas nós
também
ora está encaminhando algumas vezes do
mágico
a primeira vez está nervosa não é bem
assim é então que eu fiz já podem ver
que não tem um comportamento as notas
não tem notas mantêm em volta
dentro deste envelope e ocupe uma carta
com essas cartas do baralho costuma
jogar não conhece com essa carta não faz
a mínima ideia qual é capa está aqui
pois não combinamos nada
umas coisas que podemos combinar se
quiser por exemplo que uma carta dentro
de um envelope confirma que é o único
voto lá dentro com firmas não tem carta
o governo ainda não tem cartolas não tem
nada lá dentro eu vou deixar assim a
carteira certo e então voltou a morar de
cartas
vou fazer quando voltar a morar de
cartas favor e outro de cor as cartas
fora do baralho
a primeira caixa não é
a estrada caixa caixa vc não tem um
oscar do ano mostra assim faz um livro
com as pessoas têm uma forma sensual é
também utilizado no particular
importância de contratar todos olhavam
embaralham que as cartas não deixe que
acham que as cartas um cara estava em
inglês que trabalha assim
agora vou ter que fazer um leque inteiro
uma carta qualquer toque irá mexer
alguma ajuda para uma nova casa para ir
e voltar e que mostra a carta apresenta
conseguem ver aqueles que se não
conseguir o papel que a carta em viseu
santa carolina é tem essa capacidade
espetacular no verão invisível e vai
dizer
faltou a gente quando é quarta colocada
pelo menos quatro copas de mauá carolina
pelos vistos
eu estou vendo um treinamento com as
copas das quatro copas nunca trocar não
quer ver algumas coisas que eu chamo
mesmo quatro copas não estamos
combinados podem confirmar esse pronto a
gente quatro copas lembrança da carteira
e eu mostrei a alckmin e tal que nos
disse eu tenho colocado aqui
envolvimento correto não seria à mostra
a tatuagem não seria espetacular se esta
carta fosse precisamente na outra mas o
quatro copos à cartum livremente
escolhida pela turbina
obrigado
pode sentar e trabalhar porque sou
estrela que foi ela que o truque é
verdade não fiz rigorosamente nada é
verdade é verdade é assim que nós mas
estamos a viver é usar as carteiras
propõe o voto das notas mas mexe e os
truques agora a parte mais chata mas que
eu mais quero é curiosa struck chamas
wing walking foi criada pela empresa que
eu falei um pouco com esse médico foi
criada e idealizada por mágico gonçalves
viu que é português e foi desenvolvido
ou seja produzido o tempo a idéia dessa
carteira nós pois é preciso que a
carteira da vila e foi produzido tamanho
pela mesma empresa hoje é comercializado
e mágicos de todo mundo comprou ontem
comprar o textro bom e agora em pedir
ajuda de outra pessoa também não vai ser
aquela proibidas a favor e somente a ela
assim assim a frente sobre o problema é
que isso é fundamental ouvir novamente a
treinar mas aqui não
após uma manhã muito vai me que é o amor
que ela tem essas cartas muito mas muito
vai tomar nenhum gol e acho que ele não
está completo e preciso no brasil
completa exatamente está com essas
cartas muito bem todas as cartas
diferentes entre si é um baralho
comportamento normal das 52 cartas com
os palhaços assim também e agora amiga
ela nutre uma casa qualquer acerto é
fundamental a troca do estoque também
porque essa carta não dá pra hoje não
funciona
2 paulo uma carta que eu não gosto muito
não gosto não gosto mostrar toda a gente
a exame que ela não estava muito bem mas
não as puseram fim a carta resposta um
lado eu vou postar uma das duas cartas
mesmo procurar quanto quisesse mais
falso e pela jovem certo fazer qualquer
cartaz que mostra como a gente é
fundamental que não sejam dois povos não
torcer
mas é que não está em 12 paulo não sei
como nem sei como consegui fazer isso e
sei que é estranho
ame que ela apesar de não poder ser dois
paus
vamos nos prender a carta assim porque
agora vai ter que fazer com o cinto mas
no mês passado uma decisão pra quem
quisesse eu não quero agora ver a carta
mas também não quer tomar certo ponto
final na quarta não vai diz ainda o
treino da equipe em que mostra o autor
adianta
mas de uma forma espectacular mas tem
que pegar a carta fazer assim dois falso
até porque eu acho que é um dos postes
no entanto a gente não pode ver uma
final nunca vira a carta mostra a gente
essas coisas fazer está no espaço
quem cansar que engraçado coisa melhorou
quando vamos colocar a carta um dos
povos mais ou menos assim que pela manhã
um clique o coxinha tomar um contrato
com outra também não deixa escapar
agora só vou tentar encontrar a sua
carta
no fundo a atenção que o irmão continua
clara 4 diz padre anchieta em um país
que tem grande potencial para a energia
tem uma paixão por animais marinhos e da
marinha é triste ver o bebê ser no canal
13 na entrevista quando os mais novos e
fiquei fiquei apaixonado por animais
marinhos
então isso tem a ver com isso estamos já
conselhos que me sinto em tour para a
segunda tac tem dois paus e posso ver o
tempo com seu horário porque o baralho
para o nosso processamento nem o pior e
compartilhá lá dentro
muito obrigado porque certamente o real
estaria conosco golfo é verdade e minhas
tensões o cartola mas eu não consegui
arranjar thomas propaz é verdade é
verdade
esse truque foi criado também por uma
empresa chamada que estava sendo o total
esteve aqui meu objetivo aqui nos
contrato foi também realizado por é um
audi circunstância em que pensou em que
teve a idéia de se trocar
eu não vou dizer qual é que é mas vocês
vão escalar 15 tentava fazer isso e
lembranças truque de vigarista andar -
rio
e então eu o plano de se segurar e se
transformar num aquário com um peixinho
lá dentro de nós é espetacular
então mais uma vez os mesmos mas diz que
foi a pouco produziram e sua trupe e
hoje eu também é comercializado por todo
mundo e já foi visto por um programa
neto chamado usar droga tudo lhe viu que
é um programa na web de uma loja
britânica chamada world match shop vende
e venderá entrou que explora todo mundo
em alguns dos meus mais de fim do mundo
já nos contataram para precisamente
comprar e as trocas podem ver optou
então por trazer essas noções
complemento na minha opinião que são
trocos patacoadas mas também acho isso
exatamente foram criados por mágicos
portuguesa e como podem ver em portugal
abrange alguns mágicos
só é pena que agora voltará nunca traz a
magia também poderia estar um caminho
melhor para vocês verem mas não mais uma
curiosidade
eu tenho algumas econômica é que uma
colega vamos apresentar
nós provavelmente vamos ter tempo porque
se para espanha já uma coisa chamada
naval o que significa nesse congressos é
necessário que os mágicos que vão o
concurso tem um oval de uma instituição
uma sociedade mágica que tá aí que seja
conhecida por firmo ou o tal fantasia
temos uma instituição cá em portugal
precisamente aqui no porto é conhecida
pelo ativismo mas eu simplesmente não
nos der não nos querem dar o aval
nossa primeira morte
propor a rã precisamente ganhar prêmios
nós acreditamos mesmo que podemos ser
premiados porque é também mais uma
lacuna que nós encontramos na magia
porque temos econômica alguns mágicos
mas não há
não aquela rotina que nós está disposto
a rir e aí foi isso que nós criamos
vocês verão gosto fazer aqui um pequeno
espanhol e vamos ter mulher
vocês não podem ver tudo e hoje já tem
piada show era podem a figura da mulher
já estão a ver o que vai sair é verdade
e então o que acontece é que não nos dão
meia volta e nós provavelmente vamos ter
que atuar para espanha
é uma pena mas é assim que as coisas
funcionam desde já muito obrigado
sporting estava com carinho espero que
tenha ficado a conhecer um pouco mais da
magia e já sabem continua a ver magia
antal são já contratados estavam tal
como o cartão por aí
portanto muito obrigado mais uma vez
quero agradecer o convite aos cápsula
está aqui por exemplo na primeira edição
do táxi cap portanto até a próxima muito
obrigado por tudo